but I really need to hear it recorded
the vin diesel said that you watching
something on videos no you do good how
do you do the by the way I'm just been
reading comics for 25 years and you just
have that much confidence to explain the
holes some of the stuff I have to look
up oh yeah Robert Jefferson comics
explained yeah some of it I have to look
up but most of it's just a pyramid
Robert we appreciate you there's there
are times even the veteran comic book
fan needs to have someone explain it all
to them and the fact that you do the
research and the fact that you've been
so loyal to comments it's such a fan of
comics helps the world in more ways than
you realize we appreciate you rock Wow
[Laughter]
ok first question is I've been dying to
ask this who wins in a quarter mile race
blood-shod for Dominic Toretto winds up
for you come on the quarter mile okay
that day you can good luck son indeed on
that okay okay anything else you were
good anything else yeah okay okay second
question then who wins in a fight blood
shot or Riddick that's a good question
because the data would prove bloodshot
and yet their mindset of Riddick
that's tricky cuz his mind is so he's
like that it's uh I don't know I I don't
know how ridiculous something and that's
fascinating these are very different
characters by the way you've mentioned
Dom Toretto you've mentioned Riddick
part of the fascination with playing
this character is how different he is
from them Riddick Dom Toretto and
totally different genres but there are
always three steps ahead and we
appreciate that when we trust that about
them ray garrison bloodshot it's so in
the dark that it's one of the things
that was compelling about playing the
character talk about a character so
vulnerable talk about a character that
both evokes fear and empathy at the same
time and you as a comic book fan and a
fishing out of that nose legend law and
those whole storylines can appreciate
the blood side in a way that the public
may not in that you and you have
recognized bloodshot both in more of a
heroic position and more and villain
position depending on what who you talk
to if you talk about harbor judge he's
sometimes the worst nightmare yeah well
that was kind of my final question is
bloodshot I think it's probably one of
the more interesting characters and
company but sure but it's one that I'm
not a lot of people know about it greed
so you are bringing a character that not
a lot of people have heard of on the
silver screen well set in the face of a
new franchise to Elsa what's that like
man well at first I'm gonna be honest it
was challenging if it wasn't for my
son's conviction at the time there's a
daddy you are bloodshot and now thinking
about I have to think about what that
really means
oh but it was
that's what's challenging if you know
all the bloodshot story line you're
dealing with a very complex character
and depending on which comic book you're
reading you might see him differently
this is not a character that is born
from the convention of superheroes that
were accustomed to he's not from a
planet of superheroes he didn't wake up
want him to be altruistic could do the
right thing or save the world he simply
is a protagonist that is oppressed or
manipulated for so long
that at some point he rises perfectly I
appreciate him in you are awesome what's
up girl what's it
okay so solid would be bloodshot it's
amazing I'm glad you liked it yeah it
was it's really really solid okay so so
your career is it's pretty celebrated
and pretty lengthy yeah so going from
that into like comic book movies yeah
what's that like I love it I so I don't
know if a lot of people know this but
I'm such a nerd and the reason why is my
brother's 12 years older than me so I
had all his hand downs and is that what
you say hand outs him Adele's yeah
hand-me-downs yes so basically you know
I was I grew up in the 90s and he had
all these comic books and I sort of
would look at them at night with like a
little lantern and I became such a nerd
and I grew up playing Zelda and I like
loved playing video games and so I
obviously I'm sort of quite quite
tomboyish just being around men all my
life and so I loved it and I always
wanted to be part of it and there was a
clonic characters that I want to be part
of and other ones that I kind of kind of
this like never it was so exciting to
come across with Katie because I had
like all it was kind of do it your own
and I had never thought of that you know
especially in the world of Marvel and DC
it's kind of the repetitive like you
kind of changed casts and this was my
opportunity to make her unique and only
and no one
it doesn't even exist in the comic book
so she got created for me and now she
will exist in the comic books for
bloodshot which is incredible like that
for me very exciting yeah well that was
my next question is like one of the like
Marvel and DC are awesome right but like
their universes are huge so they could
make movies for hundreds of years but
one of the best things about valiant is
its it's easy to follow it's a small
continuity and and for your character
Katie like she's wholly new right so not
only are you playing a care does never
been seen before a character that's
gonna be in comics yes what's it like to
play somebody who's essentially brand
new to a brand new comic book franchise
amazing it was just exciting because it
took off all the pressure I feel like
the times that I've been up for roles
that are well-known I was you know it
just puts so much pressure on you and
what is the right thing to do when it's
wrong I don't want to do it wrong - it's
like the fans and you want to like live
up to the expectation and so it puts so
much pressure on you and then this was
just sort of like I wanted to make her
real and I was lucky enough to come
across with a script that made her real
as well like she had that perfect
balance between being independent and
really obviously badass and capable of
doing whatever she wanted but she's also
a completely emotional character and she
is the heart of the movie and that
rarely happens in one role you kind of
are as a woman especially in action
films you're an archetype you're like
they're badass and tough and it's gotten
better now I feel like with me to
movement and like the consciousness
about being more like smart with writing
female characters but it was you know it
took so long for that to happen and she
kind of felt right in that sense and
she's smart and she's capable and so I
love that about her and I could give her
my look in my own life and bring
whatever I wanted to do so we could
experiment with the look and I love like
the manga type of look the anime like
the hair the tattoos are like outfits
that she wears this kind of Japanese
inspired so and I love David's vision so
it was a no brainer for me okay um it's
my last question any funny or crazy
stories from filming I mean there was
like it was a whirlwind for me this film
because I was so far from home I was in
Cape Town and obviously I'm with you
technically the only woman and on set
like the whole movie
so you know it was hard because being
far from family and just being like I
couldn't really do much and I was like
rolling with the boys all the time but
crazy experience I think that was just
like being able to do all the physical
work like that when I went into the the
pool and did the diving and did Jiu
Jitsu underwater like it was important
for me to do it because it isn't an
emotional scene it's about the eyes and
the connection and if it would have been
just my stunt it wouldn't have worked
the same so I was very emmett about
doing it and it was scary because you
are physically being weighted into a
pool but it was so gratifying because I
had had an accident and I was doing it
against all odds and seeing the result
was really incredible so I was really
proud of myself awesome I love the movie
appreciate it thank you were supporting
thank you
for the blood shot film you know and
with you guys you guys in particular you
know you guys are really fascinating no
spoilers yeah oh no dumping yeah
spoilers for everybody but one of the
coolest things that I that I enjoyed
about it is that it's it's
self-contained it's easy to grasp you
know and it's fun you know there's a
good twist as well you know it's not
just linear I think um like a lot of
action movies you know they have this
kind of kind of linear story or
narrative but this one after a while it
really gets you thinking I think that's
what the hook is as well it does and
that's that's one of the cool things is
like it's just it kind of goes and then
it just comes out of nowhere right and
that was it that was important for Dave
if I remember while we were filming
there are a lot of times you would see
him in his head thinking about a
particular shot that he wanted because
he wanted it to look different from a
different shot based off these twists
and he was so hands-on he was in he was
so
directed you know as far as his vision
goes that it made our jobs a lot easier
yeah so what was your favorite part
I guess so the of the movie right
because I feel like that's a fun fun
question selfishly for me is anything
that I'm in anytime I'm on camera I mean
there's so many cool parts in there I
mean there's so many it is this is like
the set action pieces which are that I'm
in that are really cool
but we decide so much fun it's like such
such such fun to go to work and beat
play these characters and then what I
think is really cool is that they're now
violin or you know making these
characters into into their comic site
yes so we've created these characters
yeah unless they like a question right
like like you guys are playing
characters that are in the comic book
landscape right and like the characters
that you're playing are being adapted
into yeah comic that's insane yeah
that's my question like what's it like
to see yourself in a comic i it's unreal
you know what I mean first of all being
a part of this project for me is surreal
based off of the fact that when you're a
kid you're e comics and you play with
the trading cards and you pretend to be
this super hero of that super hero and
now you're involved in something of this
magnitude is already insane but then now
to have someone's wrong you pay for what
you did into the comic that's that's
pretty I'm gonna get your little figure
why's it got me a little and then while
he's pretty soon because you're small
okay so any funny stories I got one yeah
go on mine's well mine VIN promised me a
birthday present long story short he
didn't get it I'm gonna just throw it
how was this long story short he was my
birthday first day of shooting and he's
like y'all shouldn't have told me there
and I'm still waiting for a birthday
present no you gotta tell this story
then yeah we got to get the story story
well that's pretty much just two years
later I'm still waiting for my damn gift
okay this man drives around in fancy
cars all that got-dang time and he
couldn't buy me a corona Modelo is
something something yeah one of those
fancy cars so what do you think was one
like coolest experiences like being in a
comic book movie I mean yeah to be
honest you know you spend a lot of it a
lot of the action secret is a lot of the
filming we had this incredible sets in
South Africa and the rst facility it was
when we first walked into it like all
those machines are all moving and doing
their own thing it was kind of like wow
this is this is amazing but then when
you actually see the finished
you know there is green-screen there's
some you know when we're doing a lot of
the fighting you know we're not in a
moving elevator we're just in this fixed
spot - so to see all the added extra
effects I think a remarkable but it
doesn't feel like you know a lot of
movies they're overly sort of relying on
special effects you know a lot of hours
we had wet built a lot of our equipment
you know the arms that I have they built
these actual models so I think it really
feels kind of almost like you know the
older movies like aliens or yes Star
Wars you know that they actually had the
models I think it feels a bit like that
oh yeah I remember when whenever I watch
these movies if you see that nerd like
my character layer or in his facility it
looked CGI it looked like all those
things weren't real so I remember
getting a message from Dave sending me
photos of the the worked van that I'd be
in and I was so confused I just thought
in this like green screen and then we'll
just make up stuff he's like no dude all
this stuff works
every computer in here everything works
you can play with every single thing in
here now do you know how to play with
them that's a different story
but for me it was just fun to be in that
world to know that if I press this
something turns on yeah awesome guys
well uh that's it for me so thank you
awesome thanks a lot